[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER: Great design
happens within constraints.
And those constraints
are good because it
helps narrow your focus.
There's something about the
pressure and, in many cases,
conflict that
creates good things.
So in our context, the sprint
is a very focused intense period
where we have a team of
people coming together
from different
disciplines and focusing
on solving a specific
design problem.
In this case, we're
doing a sprint
at a pretty massive size.
MALE SPEAKER: Too often, there's
a process where one group works
on something and then they
hand it to the next group.
And then that group
hands to the next group,
and it gets-- something
gets lost in translation.
So this is a mechanism where
we can all get together
on the same page, because
we're all in the same room,
and you get much more tangible
results much more quickly.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Product
managers, engineering,
designers-- it's really
a chance for us all
to work very closely
together, and to really
see product development
through the eyes of others
that are on the team.
FEMALE SPEAKER: The
ability to kind of leapfrog
the traditional design
process is incredible.
Here is a chunk of time.
Here's a bunch of
experts, and we're
going to make sure that
you have everything
you need to just focus
and come together and be
super successful.
MALE SPEAKER: I think a lot
of people's idea of creativity
is you have this
freedom, you know,
leaning back in their chair
just imagining things,
and it's not like that at all.
MALE SPEAKER: Watching what
was going on yesterday--
was a lot of arguing.
There was a lot of
dissatisfaction.
And they had to figure
their way through that.
And so today, they're actually
testing their prototypes
and getting validated or
changing tack a little bit.
And that's kind of
the magic of it,
when you see these transitions
that these teams go through.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I like
it because then that way
you have kind of a go-to
person in that new store.
FEMALE SPEAKER: A lot of
what comes out of Sprint Week
is this intangible
camaraderie that
helps us work better together.
But the second part
is the projects.
A significant number of
projects come to life
as is or very close to what
comes out of Sprint Week.
MALE SPEAKER: What
we're trying to do
here is create very high
quality deliverables
that turn into real products.
MALE SPEAKER: An actual
artifact at the end
that you can then take
to engineering to build
or you can take to customers
to get more feedback on.
MALE SPEAKER: We hope that there
will be a lot of the projects
that people are working
on that will get picked up
in some form or another, but
there's really no losers.
When you participate
in a Sprint,
you either win or you learn.
[CHEERING]
MALE SPEAKER: On your
marks, get set, go!
MALE SPEAKER: There's ideas
that get cross-pollinated.
People are making connections.
People are having the
chance to work with others
that they don't normally
get to work with.
MALE SPEAKER: Maybe they only
knew each other via email,
but now they actually
really know one another.
And they have insight
into the things
that they each
respectively work on.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Every
piece together here
is bigger than the
actual sum of the parts.
There's something bigger and
more special happening here.